so if there was you know God forbid a
conflict involving us involving South
Korea in North Korea what would what we
look yeah let me let me go to this map
if I can first of all again for
orientation Seoul and its proximity to
the demilitarized zone is what we call
this and then Pyongyang is up here these
two by point of references where the
missile launchers have been taking place
and where the missile development and
nuke development is taking place so if
we were going to have if the North
Koreans were going to invade there are
two essential invasion quarters one is
from the town of Khe Sahn and it goes
further south to the South Korean town
of moose on and then the other one is
the chor one corridor so these two
corridors vector right into Seoul but
what you see today is a heck of a lot of
urbanized glass buildings residential
parks business industrial parks it
exists all these invasion quarters now
are what we call urban eyes very
compartmentalized terrain not valleys
also let me let me point this up you can
see the mountain ranges that exist up
here in the north from about north
northwest to northeast like this but
what's important to point out let me do
this on the North Slope of these
mountain ranges is where the artillery
pieces are located in caves so the worst
thing that could happen is the zero
warning scenario where these artillery
pieces are brought out and then they
start to launch into Seoul and if you're
mean launching we're talking about
conventional weapons on weapons right
yeah you're talking about how many
missiles going towards Seoul how many
Rockets and and the effect and how quick
because we're talking what second
seconds this is flight time is probably
45 seconds to a minute that how long it
would take a rocket going from here into
Seoul these are these are artillery
pieces exactly correct and rockets and
missiles are kind of co-located with
here as well and the only thing we can
do initially is where there's going to
be a blow in Seoul it's going to be hit
there will be death there will be some
destruction that occurs but our air
force is so capable what will happen is
our air force will make this kind of
emotion to come down flight paths to go
after this because you can only after
these artillery pieces because you can
only attack those from the north to the
south but a lot of these are in caves
you're saying they're in caves but they
have to pull them out to fire them
when they
start to fire them they become very
vulnerable